it's insulting what you're doing
get the [ __ ] out of here um i'm gonna
follow you so you can do it
he is definitely getting lost i heard
would you like a
fancy coffee
belly and then we have
the the desert shirts yeah the special
edition special edition joshua tree
shirts right
and it's like um these are what they
look like and these are dope too
it even has the taco bell hot fire sauce
on the front yeah it's a taco bell hot
fire sauce
so please go to our merch department i
don't know how it works go ahead
go to our website sleptkingdom.com don't
sleep on it
don't sleep on it it's gonna sell
look at out in the boots
i'm gonna document this early riser
it's 1 30. it's a lot earlier than you
usually
wake up
pretty good bed how do you sleep overall
what's your uh
rate from one to ten from that last bed
it's like night and day what was the
last bed we were at
the other house that we're at when i was
sunken in the middle and
[Laughter]
i could not sleep on that one this was a
pretty good bag pretty good room
everything was good yeah the bed was so
cozy
the pillows were good too the pillows
were great it's a good place
enjoy it um the light coming through did
it bother you
no because i told george and gilbert
they had to get you a sleepy man good
did you
go on a hike with them yeah we went on a
couple walks today
um george and gilbert were here earlier
um we walked with them
um
yummy to make you breakfast with um rice
and bacon and eggs
yeah all right cool i'll do that hello
[Music]
so we don't have um we don't have signal
signals in the car no we don't have gps
it's it's no it's off the grid so we are
going to be making a left here
where right back into that room right
there
[Music]
but i think this is the correct
direction
there there's george and gilbert where
is it
oh it's out here what are you going this
way for me i just got we got everything
set up so we're going to come back and
make sure you guys are good
you know what i don't like the fact that
you don't think that i know what i'm
doing
i'm i'm a [ __ ] i'm an expert at math
okay all expertise it's insulting what
you're doing get the [ __ ] out of here
um i'm gonna follow you so you can do it
he is definitely getting lost
i'm not gonna go where they want me to
go make me so mad
i could assure you guys of that that's
just
what i'm saying why are you why are they
following us
because you i told them not to because i
told them
it was cruising do you think their car
just like
oh yeah but it's fine i have to do
youtube
yeah because we gotta get this down the
sun we're chasing the sun
maybe
you know bob is going extra fast to lose
you oh yeah
i hope he knows there's one there's a
one way uh i hope he knows that's not
one of two ways sorry that's a
narrow one lane way oh that gets up
ahead
i've gone that fast yeah he's seen this
other car he knows
got it yeah
[Music]
no we
sit here sit here don't move
well guess where i guess we're recording
back in l.a the next episode
uh so bobby so my i think my
understanding of this is that
he because of your energy he was like oh
they want me to keep going even though
it's literally right before
it starts so he thinks that's why we're
going so slow
should we forget them or see how they're
going to smash it through this car
please don't it's my run my car my name
otherwise understand what you said
okay
to make phone calls press the phone pick
up button and say something like
call john smith call john smith call
john
six smith five five one
[Music]
hey
no electricity
here is actually the trailer that uh was
in my front yard in la
and i stayed in for was it six months
well i was a senior producer at disney's
maker studios i stayed in here
this is going to be my one of my last
tiger bellies
because i'm going to die out here so
there was there's a there's
i said the turner
let me see if i got that right yeah oh
did you get up here you get duke
oh there's no there's no
okay
dog please don't kill my lover well it
looks like george is going through the
driving yeah
george don't kill the don't kill my
lovers don't go so
uh fast whole thing was just welded by a
couple of hillbillies
hey matt doesn't work
[Music]
i don't have people did you see that
these two seat belts uh they they left
these two should work the one on the
right i did not
the one on the right doesn't have one
jules do you have a seat belt
[Music]
oh my god first time
what why are we doing this oh you got a
little fast i'm not afraid
george i'm not afraid scores about a
frag
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
i had a secret film doors but we're on
our way right now we bought bobby taco
bell he
last minute what was the order the order
was all right so here's the order it was
five tacos
two bean burritos two burrito supremes
two
uh chicken soft tacos and a lot of fire
sauce a lot of fire sauce two types of
desserts
and the best thing was he said all that
and he went
do you think jules wants anything
five hard tacos two beaveries
you got fried balls that's a dessert hey
we got all the desserts available sir
you got fried balls yeah fried ball baby
still pretty warm so once you get them
just spray right there right here uh
well let me taste it see if it's good
that's not on us where's my diet coke
that's not oh shoot they didn't give it
to us
i'm being serious i'll be honest
honestly dude just be honest with me dad
did you forget to order it
be honest with me and i'll let it go if
your taco bell's never no
would you like a dye a red bull he
ordered it
i heard him i heard would you like a
fancy coffee
hey man is this a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god